السلام عليكم واهلا بكم سقط اليوم مزيد من
القتلى والجرحى في تفجير عبوتين ناسفتين
داخل مسجد جنوب سامراء وجاءت اخر قرارات
الحكومه في شكل امر باغلاق مساجد التابعه
لديوان الوقف السني في ثلاث محافظات وهو
ما جعل خطيب الجمعه في مدينه سامراء يصف
القرار بوصمه عار في جبين الحكومه
العراقيه والسياسيين عموما نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
لماذا فشلت الحكومه العراقيه حتى الان في
ايجاد الحل الامثل لاستتباب الامن في
العراق
وما هي السيناريوهات المقترحه لاخراج
العراق من ازمتين سياسيه وامنيه ثبت
ترابطهما
تستمر اذن عجله العنف الدائره في العراق
بوتيره شبه يوميه وقد خلفت خلال الشهر
الماضي وحده نحو 800 قتيل بينما تؤكد
الامم المتحده ان عدد القتلى خلال يوليو
تجاوز الالف وهو اكبر عدد خلال شهر واحد
منذ خمس سنوات ارقام تجسد الى حد كبير فشل
الحكومه العراقيه في وقف نزيف العنف رغم
قرارات يعتبرها البعض تؤجج فتيل العنف
عوضا عن اخماده على غرار قرار اغلاق مساجد
تابعه لديوان الوقف السني في ثلاث محافظات
عراقيه
لم يجف مداد وثيقه الشرف الوطني التي وقع
عليها بعض قاده الكتل السياسيه والجهات
الدينيه والاجتماعيه في العراق يوم الخميس
حتى دوت من جديد ذات التفجيرات الدمويه
القاسيه التي ظل العراق يعاني منها ومن
اسبابها وتداعياتها طيله السنوات الماضيه
انفجرت اثناء صلاه الجمعه قنبلتان كانتا
مخباتين داخل وحدتي التكييف بمسجد في بلده
المفرق جنوب سامراء مما ادى كما هو الحال
دائما لمصرع وجرح عشرات مثل هذه التفجيرات
تكاد تكون الشفاء يوميه تطول مختلف
المواقع بما فيها المرافق العامه ودوريات
الشرطه والامن وغيرها وتشير الاحصائيات
الى مصرع نحو 800 عراقي خلال شهر اغسطس
الماضي وحده
ترى دوائر كثيره ان حكومه نور المالكي
فشلت في ضمان وحفظ امن العراقيين ولكن
دوائر اخرى تحمل كل الاطياف السياسيه
المسؤوليه بشكل او باخر خاصه وان عدم
الاعتراف بالاخر وبحقوقه يكاد يكون قاسيا
مشتركا بين مختلف الكتل والكيانات وياتي
في هذا السياق ما ذكر عن اغلاق مساجد
التابعه للوقف السني في ثلاث محافظات
عراقيه الامر الذي وجد رفضا واستنكرا
واعتبر ادانه للحكومه وكل السياسيين
العراقيين
لابد التي عرفت في البلد فسادا
وثيقه الخميس نصت على حمايه نسي العراقيين
الاجتماعي وصيانه وحدتهم الوطنيه مع رفض
اي تفرقه بينهم على اساس الدين او القوميه
او المذهبيه واعتماد مبدا الحوار سبيلا
وحيدا لمعالجه المشكلات التي تعترض مسار
البلاد السياسي
يوما بعد يوم ومع استمرار اعمال العنف
تفرض الورقه الامنيه نفسها بشده ويظل
الشارع العراقي بانتظار عوده الثقه
المفقوده بين الفرقاء بما قد يعين على
تجميع الخيوط الامنيه المتبعثره لكن لا
احد يعرف متى وكيف سيحدث ذلك
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه من بغداد مع عدنان
السراج عضوئتلاف دوله القانون ومن عمان مع
وليد الزبيدي الباحث المتخصص في الشؤون
العراقيه ولعلنا نبدا من بغداد والسيد
عدنان السراج والسؤال الاكثر الحاحا لماذا
فشلت الحكومه العراقيه الى حد الان في
استثباب الامن في العراق
بسم الله الرحمن
يعني لدينا
التساؤلات تساؤلات يجب ان تكون باستل واضح
نطرحها على
البحث بشكل يمكن ان تكون الموضوعيه
الحكومه و موضوعيه الحكومه تجاه المواطنين
نفسرها بالتفصيل الحكومه العراقيه تشكلت
من مجموعه من الاحزاب والكتل السياسيه
التي اشتركت في بناء العمليه السياسيه وما
يجري اليوم في العراق لا يجري بعناوين
التصعيد المستوى الامني او تخريب عمل
الحكومه انما يجري بشكل منسق ومنظم من اجل
تخريب العمليه السياسيه اجمالا هم يقولون
ان القضيه سنيه شيعيه وان هناك استهداف
لمكون على حساب مكون وانه هناك تهجير كلها
تدخل ضمن برنامج وهذا البرنامج اعتقد
الدوله العراقيه الان بدات تدرك ان
المساله تحتاج الى سعيد سياسي من اجل لجم
بعض الدول ولجم بعض المنظمات التي تدعم
هذا المشروع والتي لا تستطيع الحكومه
العراقيه لوحدها رئيس الوزراء
يذهب الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قريبا وسيحمل معه مشروع واضح المعالم
بالاسماء وبالاشخاص وبالدول الداعمه ويحمل
المجتمع الدولي المسؤوليه ما يجري في
العراق من تخريب الواقع السياسي بعنوان
طائفي وهذا هو الذي يمكن ان نفصله في هذه
الحلقه لكن الحكومه اليس لها ربما ايد
فيما يجري الان من تردي للاوضاع الامنيه
هناك من يحملها بان عوض ان تخمد هذه
الفتنه هي تزيد من تاجيجها ليس اخر ما
يمكن ان يذكر هو اغلاق مساجد تابعه للوقف
السني
وهل يعقل ان دوله او حكومه تفعل بنفسها ما
يقال هل من المعقول ان تكون دوله فيها من
السنه وشيعه والشيع والكرد والتركماني من
يحكم العراق بهذه الصوره هل من المعقول ان
تقوم حكومه تريد الامن والامان ان تفعل
بنفسها هذا هذا الكلام لا يمكن ان يؤخذ
بنظر الاعتبار الاخذ بنظر الاعتبار ما
يمكن ان نسميه بالمحاولات الحديثه لجبر
العراق الى حرب طائفيه وجر العراق على ان
يكون مستوى واحد بما يجري في سوريا وهذا
ما ياتي يعني تعلمين ان التصعيد الامني
بدا قبل حوالي سبعه اشهر وثمانيه اشهر بعد
تدهور الوضع في سوريا وايضا في مسجد في
ذات الحدود العراقيه السوريه ودعوه دوله
العراق الاسلاميه لن تصلح دوله العراق
والشام الاسلاميه والان هناك
الاتجاه كيف يمكن ان يفهم قرار مثل هذا
الذي اتخذته هي الحكومه ليست ايادي خارجيه
او طرف اخر هو من اتخذ هذا القرار باغلاق
مساجد التابعه للوقف السني
وفي ثلاث محافظات عراقيه
بالنسبه للمساجد اختي العزيزه ليكون معلوم
للجميع المساجد السنيه تابعه للوقف السني
والوقف السني هو الذي يحدد اليات فتحها
واغلاقها هيئه مستقله لا دخل لرئيس
الوزراء فيها الوقف السني والوقف الشيعي
هو تحت اشراف مجلس النواب وبالتالي كل
الحسينيات وكل الجوامع والكنائس التي تنضم
الى الهيئات المستقله سواء كانت السنه او
الشيعه او الاديان الاخرى او المسيحيه فهي
لا سلطه للحكومه عليها بالمطلق وليكن ذلك
معلوما النقطه مثيره اشرت اليها دعنا
نتحول بها الى ضيفنا من عمان السيد وليد
الزبيدي اذا لا دخل اطلاقا لحكومه الملك
فيما يجري من ترد الاوضاع الامنيه وحتى
اخر قرار يتم ربما الجدل بخصوصه وهو اغلاق
المساجد ليست الحكومه المسؤوله عنه بما
يمكن الرد على ذلك
الاداريه رئيس الوقف السني هو مستشار
واقرب شخص الى السيد نور المالكي والجانب
الثاني انه محاوله
للايحاء بان الوضع وصل الى حد الرعب فعليه
ان يتم تهجير عدد كبير من الناس من هذه
المناطق وما قاله او تفضل به السيد السراج
ربما لا يقتنع به الكثير من العراقيين لكن
سيد وليد هناك العديد من ربما التحليلات
التي تشير بان تردي الوضع الامني لا تقع
المسؤوليه عليه كامله على الحكومه هذا ان
اقررنا بان على حكومه اي دوله ان تضمن امن
مواطنيها هناك اتهامات للطرف الاخر سمعت
ما قاله سيد سراج بان اياد اجنبيه تعبت في
امن العراق
يعني القضيه ينظر لها من زاويتين انا
استطيع ان اتهم
موريتانيا واتهم الصين واتهم اي دوله
بانها تعبث بالعراق ولكن بل وثيقه التي
لدي زاويه الثانيه هناك المسؤوليه
الاخلاقيه والامنيه والحكوميه
وهم يقولوا باننا
حكومه منتخبه ولكن عندما من الجانب الاخر
عندما يصر السيد رئيس الوزراء على عدم
اعتماد كفاءات امنيه حقيقيه عندما يرفض
تعيين وزير للداخليه ووزير للدفاع خلال
الاعوام الاربعه الماضيه هذا يؤكد بان
قضيه الامن قضيه شخصيه ولاهداف حزبيه
وربما ابعد من ذلك تتعلق بالمساله
الاقليميه وكل ما يرمى على هذا الطرف او
ذاك في النهايه يعود ويرمى على الحكومه
لانها مسؤوله عن حمايه الاسواق والمواطنين
والمساجد والعلماء وكافه
وكل التهم الان التي نسمعها لا تستند الى
دليل في حين كل الاعراف والقوانين تحمل
الحكومه مسؤوليه الحفاظ على امن المواطن
مسؤوليه الحكومه على الحفاظ امن المواطن
سيد سراج نقطه يتفق معها كثيرون هل
الحكومه حكومه المالكي قامت فعليا بكل ما
يتوجب عليها من اجراءات وخطوات لضمان امن
المواطن العراقي
سوى قد يكون انا مطلع على بعض الاجراءات
لانهم بحكم قربي لدوله القانون ايضا
متابعتي من خلال المركز العراقي تنمي
الاعلاميه الحكومه العراقيه حاله اي حكومه
كالحكومه المصريه والحكومه السوريه
والحكومات الاخرى التي تحاول القضاء على
مشاكلها الحكومه المصريه حتى هذه الدقيقه
المشاكل عاصفه ونحن نعطيها فتره زمنيه
لحين انتهت الامور وتسيطر وكذلك تونس
وكذلك كل الدول الا في ليبيا لا تستطيع
الدوله ان تسيطر على مكوناتها في العراق
هناك مؤسسات دوله ثابته هناك تجربه
ديمقراطيه ثابته بالمناسبه زميلنا واخينا
العزيز استاذ وليد دائما اتوسل فيه الدقه
ولكن الان جوابه لم يكن مقنعا بالنسبه لي
يعلم جيدا ان الوثائق التي يعني اطلقتها
السفاره الامريكيه من خلال السفير السابق
من خلال جريده الجرجير البريطانيه ما يشير
بوضوح واحدث الزوبعه في
في امريكا بحيث استدعي السفير العراقي
الاستفهام عن هذه المعاني هو قال بالنص
العراقيون قد يكون من التدخل للدوله
الفلانيه ودفعها الاموال وبالتالي
قبل كم يوم وايضا وثقتها الخارجيه
الامريكيه واستدعت ايضا السفير العراقي
على التداول حول هذا الموضوع وهذه القضيه
لا تحتاج الى شهود ولا تحتاج لها وثائق
ثانيا الميليشيات ويعلم جيدا ان السيد نور
المالكي حارب المنيشات بقوه وفي البصره
وبالتالي نحن نتالم عندما نشاهد ان في
البصره ما يجري نبغى سني سني وليس صلاح
شيعي سني
شخصا
نتيجه الخصومات يعني عفوا كيف سني سيد
السراج فقط حتى نستفيد من النقاش وهناك
اتهامات
بعمليات تهجير من البصره تحديدا
الناصريه نعم
حدث غير مسبوقه والان اعاده الحكومه
اربعين عائله من ال السعدون الذين هم من
اصلاء الناصريه ونحن المكونات نعتني بها
نقول المكون هو قوه العراق اي تنوع في
المكونات هو لاي دوله في العالم قوه
الثقافات وقوه تنوع الثقافات هي قوه
للعالم لذلك نجد ان مساله التهويد في هذه
القضيه ليس ممنهجه من قبل الدوله نعم قد
تكون هناك بعض الاطراف انا لا ازكي احدا
واقول نعم هناك اخطاء قد تكون من بعض
القوات الامنيه قد تكون من بعض المسؤولين
نعم موجوده هذه قد تكون الحساسيات البذريه
تلعب دور ولكن كدوله هي تحارب هذا التوجه
وكحكومه ايضا
كما تقولونها اقليما للجنوب واقليما للوسط
واقليما للسنه وهكذا تنته عفوا فقط حتى
نتطور قليلا في النقاش ونحاول ان ربما
نتطرق الى زوايا عديده حتى ما تسميه حرب
الحكومه في هذا الصدد هناك من يرى بانه لا
جديه حقيقيه لدى الحكومه العراقيه مثلا
مطالبات من خطيب الجمعه في سامراء ذياب
السامرائي يقول بانه يطالب الحكومه
العراقيه بان تضرب من حديد ان كانت جاده
كما قالت في ملاحقه المتسببين في عمليه
القتل والتهجير الطائفي التي حدثت في جنوب
العراق اذا هناك من يرى بان الحكومه ليست
جديه تماما
هذا كلام سليم
نحتاج الى تعاون سياسي نحتاج الى دعم
سياسي دعم عشائري نعم نحتاج الى هذه
الامور تفضلت بها التهجير لا يمس السنه
فقط هناك في حزام بغداد وفي مناطق اخرى
وفي ديالى يهجر الشيعه وبالتالي اجد ان
هذه العمليات التي يراد العوده بالعراق
الى 2007 واضحه المعالم ولكن سالتيني
ونسيت ان اجيب المقطع الثاني انا من حكم
قربي للواقع الحكومه العراقيه الجاده فعلا
وخلال السنه هذه من الان الى السنه
القادمه ستكون هناك اجراءات سياسيه على
مستوى عالي واجراءات امنيه على مستوى عالي
بحيث يمكن الحد من نشاطات هؤلاء المسلحين
سواء
طلب او الطرف الاخر ثم ان هناك عمليات
كبرى سوف تجري في كل شوارع العراق من اجل
نجم حاله الارهاب في شوارع والمحافظات
الاخرى اذا اضافه الى كل ما ذكرت السيد
سراج السيد وليد الزبيدي هناك خطوات اذا
هناك نيه هناك وثيقه لسلم الاجتماعي وقعت
بالامس فقط لماذا لا تعطى فرصه لمثل هذه
الجهود لعل وعسى
يعني الموضوع الوثيقه او الميثاق الذي
يعني تم الترويج له قبل امس وقبل ذلك انا
اعتقد بان كما هو في السياسات الخارجيه
كذلك في المواثيق والسياسات الداخليه هناك
ثلاث معايير
ثلاثه معايير مهمه ورئيسيه لكل ذلك او
تتحكم بها التي هي المنفعه والخوف والشرف
اذا فككنا هذه المنافع الثلاث على اساس
هذه الوثيقه سنجد الخوف هو دافع لرئيس
الوزراء والحكومه لانه يتحكم به امران
الامر الاول الوضع الامن المتدور في داخل
العراق ويزداد تدهور والامر الثاني هو
الوضع الاقليمي وما يرتبط به من دعم حصل
عليه في دورته الثانيه عام 2010 من قبل
ايران وامريكا ايران الان تتراجع ضعفا
وامريكا شبه انسحبت من الملف العراقي ما
يتعلق المنفعه الشخصيه او المنفعه
بالتاكيد هناك وما يسرق من اموال العراق
وهذا امر اصبح مكشوف ولكن الجميع يضعون
الف علامه استفهام تحت كلمه الشرف وهو
المعيار او العامل الثالث المؤثر في هذه
في هذا الامر الان نستمع الاستاذ السراج
يتحدث عن خطط مقبله وخطط امنيه للاسف
الشديد الامريكان هزموا من العراق لانه
معتمدوا فقط الجانب القوه
والحكومه الحكومات المتعاقبه منذ حكومه
2004 حتى الان يعتمدون ذات النهج انا
اعتقد بان العوده الى ان الامن هو مجتمعي
وليس قوه واعتقالات وتعذيب واهانه وتهجير
هو السبيل الوحيد لكي نخرج من هذا المازق
الخطير على كل سنعود لمناقشه كل ذلك نذهب
الان مشاهدينا الكرام الى فاصل القصير
نناقش بعده ما طرح من سيناريوهات لاخراج
العراق من ازمتين امنيه كما ذكر ضيفنا من
عمان لكن سياسيه ايضا ثبت ترابط الازمتين
نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش تعاطي الحكومه العراقيه مع
تواصل تردي الوضع الامني اتحول الى العراق
مره اخرى الى بغداد تحديدا السيد سراج
يعني كما اشار ضيفنا الى حد الان
المعالجات كانت امنيه وامنيه فقط في ازمه
يرى البعض بان لها وجهان الوجه الامني
صحيح لكن السياسي ايضا وبانهما مترابطان
بشكل كبير يعني هل معالجه الامنيه كافيه
في هذه المرحله لاخراج العراق من هذه
المعضله
نعم بالتاكيد الازمه السياسيه تلعب دور
كبير وهذا واضح ولذلك يجد ان المساله التي
تحرك السياسي سيكون كامل وشامل وستبدا
عمليات المشاورات مع الدول المنطقه والدول
العالميه من اجل وضع برنامج من لمكافحه
الارهاب ومكافحه العراق نقطه نقطه
اطراف خارج
من خلال مبادره السيد رئيس الوزراء من
خلال وثيقه السلم الاجتماعي التي وقعت يوم
امس بحضور اغلب قاده الكتل السياسيه
بالمناسبه هناك ايضا تحركات من اجل عبور
الكتل السياسيه للمنهج الطائفي بالعناوين
المعلنه حيث من المحتمل ان تنحل او تناقش
مساله المتظاهرون واليوم سمعنا ان هناك
خطوات عمليه باتجاه التفاوض وحل مشاكل
المتظاهرين بعيدا عن الصراخ الطائفي
وبالتالي نوع من الاله ان كنت تسمعني
العمليات
الواقع السياسي العراقي باتجاه وحده
سياسيه قادره على ان تشكل كل اطياف الشعب
العراقي خصوصا اذا هناك تقارب بين متحدون
ودوله القانون والتحالف الوطني اصبح واضحا
وجنيا في اكثر المناسبات وما قام به السيد
النجيفي من محاولات لتقريب وجهات النظر
وحضور اكثر الاجتماعات من بدء وثيقه السن
الى مساله المبادره الى زياراته الى تركيا
وايران ويعقبها الى زياره الى قطر
والسعوديه وايضا الاردن هذه مسائي قد تكون
ثلج من واقع السياسي كما تفضلتي ولكن
بالمناسبه الواقع الامني واقع مريض الواقع
الامني تشترك فيه عده عوامل لا نستطيع ان
نحصلها الان الا في قضيه واحده يجب ان
يسمح هناك توافق حقيقي عراقي ليس سني شيعي
اليوم ما جرى في سامراء مجزره حقيقيه قتل
من ابنائنا في تلك المناطق بشكل اكثر من
100 شخص بتفجير
خطير لا يمكن ان نعجز ذلك انه هناك تصعيدا
امنيا انما هناك استهدافا امنيا وهذا
ويكون هناك ربما حوار في هذا الموضوع على
سؤال ربما لم تكن تسمعني اشرت الى العديد
من النقاط التي اود ان اتوقف عندها اشرت
بان هناك تحركات مع الخارج وهناك من يرى
بان الحكومه تصم الاذان على المتظاهرين
المتواجدين في الساحات منذ اشهر اشرت بانه
الان هناك خطوات في هذا الاتجاه قدر البعض
بانها متاخره بعض الشيء اشرت ايضا للوثيقه
التي يرى البعض بانها حتى كما هي مثاليه
كما تبدو غياب اطراف فاعله عنها لا يعطيها
مصداقيه وهناك ازمه ثقه حقيقيه وارجو لو
سمحت لو تجيبني بالايجاز
نعم هذا كلام سليم انا لا اتكلم بالمثاليه
في العراق ليس مجال لطرح المثاليه ولكن
يمكن ان نقول نجرب ونحاول وبلا محاولات
وتجربه لا يمكن ان نعيش واعتقد ان هذه
الوثيقه نعم بعض الكتل التي اصبحت الان
يعني لا تريد توقيع عليها مثل السيد صالح
المطلق والسيد علاوي اعتقد وثيقا لن تحسم
امرها بغلق ابواب التوقيع او المشاركه
اتصور السيد صالح المطلق لدي اعتراضات ليس
ببنود الوثيقه انما باليات تطبيقها او
بالنتائج التي يمكن ان تتحقق بها او ما
موجود على الارض فلذلك اعتراضاته اعتراضات
فنيه وهذه يمكن ان تحال بشكل مستمر
لدينا حديث طويل مع السيدات علاوي السيد
خضير الخزاعي قال لنا في اجتماع
للاعلاميين انه قد سلم ورقه ودعوه للسيدات
علاوي للحضور او للمشاركه ولكنه
لانني ساتحاول السيد وليد الزبيدي ليس
بهذا الحجم اعتقد صديقتك
ويمكن ان تشكل منطلقا للعمل للمستقبل منك
بشده تحول للسيد وليد الزبيدي لما بقي
معنا من وقت ونسال سيد وليد ما الحل
الامثل الان لهاتين الازمتين المترابطتين
تماما امنيه وسياسيه في ظل غياب تام للثقه
بين الطرفين
هو بالمناسبه هناك اكثر من طرفين يعني
الطرف المعارض للعمليه السياسيه هو جزء من
العمليه السياسيه وقد تكون هناك خلافات
بسيطه بين هذا الطرفين ولكن عندما تخرج
جميع محافظات العراق في 31/8 الماضي
ومحافظات اخرى من 272 يوم منتفضه ضد جميع
ممارسات العمليه السياسيه بدون استثناء
الممارسات والسرقات والاعدامات
والاعتقالات واعتقال النساء بمعنى هناك
راي جمعي ضد هذه العمليه السياسيه التي
للاسف اساءت للمواطن العراقي وساءت العراق
ودمرت شعب العراقي ونهبت
ثرواته ونقول بان الاسئله الكبيره لا تجاب
بالشعارات الان
استشف من كلام السيد السراج ضعف الحكومه
وخوفها والدليل انها ترسل الى دول جوار
وكانها هي التي تتحكم بحل مشاكل الملايين
العراقيين الذين ثاروا وانتفضوا رغم جميع
عمليات الامنيه الجانب الاخر يقول بان
السيد المالكي سيذهب الى اميركا وياخذ
اسماء الدول والشخصيات التي تعبث بامن
العراق
بتقدير هذه الطروحات وهذه القناعات تقود
الى مزيد من الفوضى مزيد من الدمار الحل
بالجانب العملي ان نقرا تفصيليا ما هي
الاخطار التي التي حدثت تحدق بالعراق وكيف
نعالجه بشكل علمي وعملي وايضا بموافقه كل
عراقي اشكرك جزيلا الشكر سيد وليد الزبيدي
الباحث المتخصص في شؤون العراقيه كما نشكر
جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من بغداد عدنان السراج
عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون ختام حلقتنا
السلام عليكم